well good evening and welcome to a
special edition of Tucker Carlson
tonight I'm will Kane in for Tucker now
here's a stat that puts the country's
collapse into perspective maybe more
than any other the Dow Jones just
recorded its eighth straight weekly loss
the last time that happened was all the
way back in 1932 around the height of
the Great Depression right now a lot of
Americans are wondering how did we get
here so quickly just a year and a half
into Joe Biden it's been a rapid decline
if you get a moment this weekend go on
the internet and pull up Joe Biden's
inaugural address looking back it's
remarkable not because of what's in the
speech but because of what's missing
from the speech you won't hear a single
mention of the issues Americans are most
concerned about nothing on inflation
poverty gas prices the stock market
nothing on government spending energy
Independence fentanyl overdoses and
absolutely nothing on border security in
fact there isn't a single mention of
policy in the entire address
instead Joe Biden talked about himself
he compared himself to Abraham Lincoln
issuing the Emancipation Proclamation he
told us that only Joe Biden could unite
Americans and save us from quote
bitterness and fury
today
on this January day my whole soul is in
this
bringing America together
uniting our people United in our nation
and I ask every American to join me in
this cause
we can join forces
stop the shouting and lower the
temperature
for without Unity there is no peace
only bitterness and fury and so today
at this time in this place
let's start afresh
so a year and a half later I think right
here on Tucker Carlson tonight we can
announce that Joe Biden has finally
succeeded in unifying the country
against Joe Biden and the polling makes
that very clear listen to this according
to a CNN survey from this week only 40
percent of Americans approve of Joe
Biden's job performance that's worse
than Jimmy Carter at the same point in
his presidency 65 percent of Americans
are concerned about the future of the
country and 21 are just flat out scared
just 14 percent are excited or
optimistic and I would love to meet that
14 percent
an NBC News poll came up with similar
numbers just 39 percent of Americans
according to NBC approve of Joe Biden's
performance 62 percent disapprove of
Biden's handling of the economy those
numbers are also worse than Jimmy
Carter's 71 of Americans 71 disapprove
of Joe Biden's handling of the cost of
living 58 upset with his border policies
and listen to this another new poll from
Quinnipiac found that Joe Biden has just
a 26 percent approval rating among
Hispanics it's his lowest among any
demographic group that's a flood of
numbers coming at you but as bad as
those numbers are there's evidence that
they could be overestimating Joe Biden's
popularity a political science Professor
named Eddie Zipperer looked at a recent
poll by Marist and the poll found that
Joe Biden's approval rating is 39 that's
in line what we saw from the other polls
but the Maris Institute poll reported
that Joe Biden's popularity was much
higher in fact almost 50 percent
among Baby Boomers and the silent
generation
can that be right Zipperer did some
number crunching and he found that 52
percent of people who are over 65 well
they voted for Donald Trump in 2020. in
the Marist Institute poll found that two
percent just two percent of people that
supported Donald Trump in 2020 now have
shifted to having a favorable view of
Joe Biden so where is this new support
for Joe Biden among Baby Boomers and the
silent generation it just it doesn't add
up and here's the point at the end of
all of this arithmetic
the polls could be overstating Joe
Biden's popularity among older Americans
and that may be due to a sampling error
if that's the case Joe Biden's lower
than 39 percent
now that would explain why no one in the
media not even CNN is bothering to
defend Joe Biden anymore
just 16 say the country's headed in the
right direction while a whopping 75
percent say we're on the wrong track in
fact that wrong track number has been 70
plus for seven months there are a lot of
push button issues that do have people
infuriated inflation at a 40-year high I
think is one of them the anxieties that
Americans are feeling over inflation
high gas prices and it's really bubbling
up you see that President Biden has a 40
approval rating in the CNN poll of polls
55 percent disapprove this is a huge
warning sign for Democrats if you were a
doctor and you were looking at this
chart you would say these vital signs
are very very bad the people are just
really pissed off they're really angry
about what's going on and they don't
feel like anyone can help them I mean
they tried it with the Trump
Administration then they switched they
handed power in Washington to Democrats
and now inflation has gone rampant
people are really unhappy with their
lives I'd say that's a fair summation 40
39 it's very very bad and people are
pissed off now from his inauguration
speech though we know Joe Biden see any
of this coming he didn't think it was
possible to wreck a functioning economy
in just a year and a half but the signs
were there the nation's monetary Supply
had grown dramatically in 2020 due to
pandemic spending but Joe Biden ignored
those warning signs he was laser focused
on demonizing his political opponents
instead of managing the economy in a
single Bill the American Rescue act
Biden spent 19 trillion dollars and
according to an article by the Federal
Reserve Bank of San Francisco that
action led directly to inflation
quote estimates suggest that the fiscal
support measures designed to counteract
the severity of the pandemic's economic
effect may have contributed to this
Divergence by raising inflation three
percentage points by the end of 2021 but
Joe Biden kept going he spent another
trillion dollars on infrastructure the
result the highest inflation rate we
have seen in decades this morning
America seems trapped in a Vortex of bad
economic news Sky High food prices pump
prices at record levels soaring rents up
16 percent in one year coveted lockdowns
in China the world's manufacturing
center choking the global supply chain
U.S corporate profits sinking Russian
oil under partial embargo Ukrainian
wheat exports at a standstill and all of
it feeding 40-year High inflation that
Americans are paying for every day
so if you're wondering how all of this
caught Joe Biden by surprise consider
who's suffering the most here the people
hit hardest by Joe Biden's economic
policies aren't in urban areas like San
Francisco or New York which are solidly
blue Joe Biden's base isn't bearing the
brunt of this his bubble is sufficiently
insulated now the people suffering the
most are in remote rural areas in small
towns towns
like Midland Texas places that are
overwhelmingly conservative it's a lot
harder to Ferry food and supplies into a
place like Midland because it's so far
from Urban centers and a fox multimedia
reporter just went to Midland which has
recorded the highest inflation rate in
the country at roughly 10 percent
people in this west Texas town of
Midland say it's hitting them hardest
we're somewhat isolated between El Paso
and Dallas Fort Worth
and so that's a lot of distance and it
takes you four or five hours to go to
either one so travel costs
Transportation costs that raises prices
Midland has a population of just over
over Phoenix and Dallas a run for their
money when it comes to inflation it's
had the highest rate in the country for
the last six months the west Texas Food
Bank says over the last few weeks the
number of families it serves has tripled
most of the clients we serve you know 27
to 30 percent of them have never needed
any form of Public Assistance before
their rent has gone up they cannot keep
up with the price of groceries that
they're seeing right now in the grocery
stores and they can't keep up with the
cost of fuel
those are my people West Texas those are
our people Americans and this is Joe
Biden's Unity strategy Americans United
in being poorer more divided and more
scared than they were when he took
office it just so happens that once
again people who didn't vote for Joe are
suffering the most
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight